Speaker 1: All right.
Let's go back to the discord lines and hear
from some more people in the audience.
David Pacman, dot com slash discord, of course,
is the only place, the only place to call
in to the show.
Important to understand there, except no substitution
I think is the point that I'm trying to make.
Let's go to Josh from Michigan.
Josh from Michigan, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind?
Hi, David.
Speaker 2: Cool.
It's nice to touch base here.
I was just thinking about I look at the 272
when they come out and I look at the map and
I see all you really need to have a stable
Democratic president going into the future
are existing blue states plus Wisconsin, Michigan
and Pennsylvania.
And the existing problem these three states
have are sort of loss of population or stagnating
population.
And my question is kind of what do you think
these three states can do to sort of gain
population and stay strong for a more progressive
future?
Because that's kind of where I'm coming from.
Speaker 1: Well, let me propose something
different to you, Josh.
You're not wrong that one way.
If you hold voter turnout level, one way for
Democrats to do better in those states would
be to get people to move to those states who
would vote for Democrats.
Certainly that's possible.
I think that there's an easier way, though.
It's much easier to get an existing Wisconsin
resident who doesn't care enough to vote to
go and vote than it is to get someone from
like Connecticut to move to Wisconsin.
Do you understand the point I'm making?
Speaker 2: Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
Speaker 1: In other words, you have the voters,
both parties have the voters to win because
voter turnout is so pathetically low in the
United States.
I think it's far easier to convince existing
Wisconsinites and Michiganders or whatever
the right term is, to just go and vote rather
than to try to get people to move there.
And the truth is, getting people to move somewhere
depends on so many things really beyond our
conversational control.
You can convince people to vote just through
a conversation about why it's important and
it doesn't require them to sell and buy a
new house, find a job, rent a U-Haul or any
of those things.
So I think the focus should be not on getting
people to move to these key states, but just
activating voters.
I will say one other thing, just because you
brought this up.
One of the real questions about 2024 is, okay,
so whether it's Trump, Biden or Biden, DeSantis,
or whatever.
If we start with the 2020 map.
We then have to say, what is the path for
Republicans to win?
And when you start looking, it's not a great
path for Republicans.
Now, I'm not saying Biden's got this.
I'm not saying that by any means, but when
you look at some of these states, Trump got
Florida in 2020, so you don't even have to
worry like Biden won and didn't get Florida.
Imagine that Georgia, which Biden won, went
to the Republican, which it often does.
That still leaves Democrats with 290 electoral
votes.
Imagine that.
Republicans also get Arizona back, which I
think has gone more blue, Josh, since 2020.
Democrats still have 279.
So the point here is not that Republicans
can't win or whatever.
My point is, if I think about 2020 and think
about what's changed, I think Georgia has
stayed as purple as it was.
I think Arizona has gone more blue.
And so Republicans do have some work to do
to get to 270 votes in 2024.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I totally agree.
Yeah, they have a lot of work to do.
And I think Michigan, for what it's worth,
has gone a little bit left since 2020, 2022.
It went for Gretchen Whitmer by 11%.
Speaker 1: Yep.
Speaker 2: And she's done some positive things
here, a little bit slower on the clip than
Minnesota, but just foundational stuff that
I think's going to be great for the future
of the state here.
Speaker 1: Excellent stuff.
All right, Josh, thank you so much for the
call.
Speaker 2: You're welcome.
Speaker 1: All right.
There goes Josh from Michigan with I mean,
those are important issues.
Nitty gritty.
Nitty gritty stuff
for sure.